[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
[Musik]
hallo liebe Zuhörer heute haben wir
einen Fall für euch der die Menschen in
und um Bremen mal sehr aufgewühlt hat
ich bin Mirko Kasimir und freue mich
dass auch diesmal die fabelhafte Toni
Heyer an meiner Seite ist hallo Mirko
danke danke ganz meinerseits und heute
müssen wir vielleicht mal über den
Begriff Cold Case sprechen klar der
bezeichnet einen ungelösten Fall und
spielt mit cold darauf an dass alle
möglichen Spuren erkaltet sind aber die
Angehörigen lässt das Geschehen
natürlich auch Jahre danach alles andere
als kalt und so ein Fall der ein heute
noch wütend macht ist der von Adelina
pismak aus Bremen Mirko öffne bitte
unsere Fallakte
wir schreiben den 28 Juni 2001 es ist
ein Donnerstag an dem in der Welt nicht
viel Aufregendes passiert im
Tennisturnier von Wimbledon sind bis auf
David prinosiel nicolas Kiefer und Anke
Huber alle deutschen ausgeschieden an
den Weltmärkten erreicht der Ölpreis
einen Tiefststand in Bremen hat die
zehnjährige Adelina pismarck am
Nachmittag ihren ober Christian Seidel
besucht der wohnt im Stadtteil
Kattenturm im elften Stock eines
Wohnblocks
Adelina holt bei ihm Brot und Wurst ab
und eine Tüte Chips für sich und ihre
vierjährige Schwester denn ihre Mutter
ist an diesem Tag krank
gegen 17:30 Uhr macht sie sich auf den
Heimweg der ist nur wenige hundert Meter
lang aber sie kommt nicht an ich will
euch Adelina mal ein bisschen näher
bringen sie ist nämlich ein niedliches
freundliches Mädchen auf den Fotos von
damals lächelt einen eine schlanke
zehnjährige etwas schüchtern aber sehr
herzlich an sie trägt eine einfache
runde Metallbrille und zwei
ungeflochtene Zäpfchen Adelina galt in
der Familie und in der Nachbarschaft als
zuverlässig und es in der Schule fleißig
der im gleichen Stadtteil lebende
Stiefvater hat ein Besuchsrecht der
leibliche Vater adelinas lebt in
Russland die ganze Familie war nämlich
erst 1990 von Russland in die
Bundesrepublik gekommen
adalinas kranke Mutter alarmiert die
Polizei und schon an diesem ersten Tag
wird großflächig nach dem Kind gesucht
ohne Ergebnis in den folgenden Tagen
wird daraus eine der bis dahin größten
Suchaktionen der Bremer Polizei die
bildet eine 40-köpfige Sonderkommission
Taucher suchen Gewässer ab Kampfjets
überfliegen die Stadt mit
Wärmebildkameras Suchhunde schnüffeln in
den Wäldern und auf Wiesen oh Mann und
die Mutter kann mit ihrer kleineren
vierjährigen Tochter nur abwarten und
Bangen ich meine das muss ja furchtbar
sein dass man sich einerseits Gewissheit
wünscht und andererseits nichts mehr als
das Adelina einfach wieder auftaucht
auch der leibliche Vater gerät ins
Visier die Polizei überprüft ob er
Adelina entführt und zu sich nach
Sibirien geholt hat das aber bestätigt
sich nicht von einer Pressekonferenz in
diesen bangen Wochen gibt es einen
ergreifendes Dokument
adelinas Mutter Oxana wendet sich an die
Öffentlichkeit und an einen möglichen
Entführer ich habe einen Teil von mir
verloren meine vierjährige Tochter
vermisst ihre große Schwester auch ganz
wenn sie mich jetzt sieht und hört ich
bin bei ihr in Gedanken und dich hoffe
dass sie wieder bei mir wird das ist
besonders tragisch weil Adelina zu
diesem Zeitpunkt längst tot ist die
Monate vergehen es ist der 7 oktober
2001 eine Frau sucht Pilze im
sogenannten pastorenwäldchen
dieses kleine Stück Grün befindet sich
in der Lester Marsch südlich von Bremen
das Wäldchen ist gerade mal 180 x 50
Meter groß die pilzsammlerin entdeckt
einen blauen Plastiksack darin die
sterblichen Überreste eines Mädchens
die Rechtsmedizin übernimmt und liefert
zwei Erkenntnisse
es handelt sich um Adelina und sie ist
vergewaltigt worden da ist die
Gewissheit die sich so aber keiner
gewünscht hat der damalige Leiter der
Vermisstenstelle Dirk Simmering sagte es
war einerseits erleichternd aber es war
auch erschütternd dort im Wald zu stehen
und diesen Leichnam von Adelina wo man
so lange gehofft hatte in dieser Form zu
finden
und auf der Seite des
Bundeskriminalamtes ist bis heute zu
lesen was Adelina damals anhatte und mit
sich geführt hat Mirko
Kleidung weißes
bündchenlangesträgershirt Größe
134/140 dunkelblauer fast schwarzer
glockenförmiger ausgestellter Minirock
aus Wolle mit ca 5 cm langem Schlitz im
Bereich des rechten Beines Form Größe
weiße Unterhose blaue Jeans Sandaletten
mit breitem jeansriemen im Bereich des
Spanns welcher mit bunten
Kunststoffperlen besetzt ist der
Zehenbereich ist frei Größe 33 34 weiße
Jutetasche halbes Graubrot in einer
Papiertüte zwei halbe Stücke
Geflügelwurst eingespeist zwei
tütenchips Pombär Schlüsselbund mit vier
Schlüsseln an einem ovalen
metallarmolett Vorderseite Eiffelturm
mit Schriftzug Paris Rückseite
Seitenansicht von Napoleon
Teleskop Regenschirm mit schwarzem Knauf
dunkler Stoff mit Karomuster aus dem
Vermisstenfall ist jetzt also ein
Mordfall geworden die Polizei untersucht
natürlich auch die Umgebung der
leichenfundstelle und wird fündig das
BKA schreibt in unmittelbarer Nähe des
ablageortes wurden sechs im Waldboden
verschartete damenbadeanzüge sowie eine
umstandsmiederhose ein Top und drei
Strumpfhosen gefunden neben
verschiedenen tätertypen aus dem
Deliktsbereich der Sexualstraftäter wird
aufgrund des Hundes der Badeanzüge nicht
ausgeschlossen dass insbesondere
Personen als Täter in Frage kommen
könnten die als transvestitisch
veranlagte Fetischisten einzustufen sind
beim transvestitischen Fetischismus wird
die Kleidung des anderen Geschlechts
hauptsächlich zu Erreichung sexueller
Erregung getragen das Tragen der Fetisch
Gegenstände oder Kleidung soll den
Anschein erwecken dass es sich um eine
Person des anderen Geschlechts handelt
in diesem Zusammenhang ist auffällig
dass der zuletzt von Adelina getragene
kurze blaue Wollrock beim Leichen von
fehlte okay das ist eine Theorie eine
Spur die nirgendwohin führt davon gibt
es später noch viel viel mehr in den
nächsten Jahren gehen mehr als 1000
Hinweise ein fast 300 bekannte Sextäter
werden überprüft ganz zu schweigen von
all den physischen Spuren am Tatort
2003 wird ein 22-jähriger Mann
verdächtigt der zuvor ein Mädchen in
seinem Auto festgehalten hatte die Spur
führt in eine Sackgasse erst zwei andere
Morde bringen wieder Bewegung in den
Fall Adelina
Norddeutschland sucht im Jahr 2004 einen
Serientäter der Kinder umbringt
innerhalb von sechs Monaten werden
zwischen Rotenburg Wümme und Stade die
achtjährige lifke und der gleichaltrige
Felix entführt und ermordet die Polizei
ermittelt einen 30-jährigen als
Verdächtigen Mark Hoffmann der aus dem
Sauerland nach Bremen gezogen war er
arbeitet für eine Sicherheitsfirma und
er war auch schon in der Vergangenheit
durch Sexualdelikte aufgefallen so
unfassbar und schlimm diese Morde sind
sie werden immerhin aufgeklärt Mark
Hoffmann besteht alles im Zusammenhang
mit den Fällen lefke und Felix und wird
in einem Prozess vor dem Landgericht
Stade zu lebenslange Haft mit
anschließender Sicherungsverwahrung
verurteilt
aber hat Hoffmann auch Adelina ermordet
es gibt erst Spuren dann sogar ganz
konkrete Hinweise darauf in Hoffmanns
Wohnung wurden kleine plastikpärchen
gefunden die man auch an adelinas
Fundort entdeckt hatte
2005 berichten Fernsehsender außerdem
noch mal mehrfach über Adelina aus
Bremen ein Mithäftling von marktkaufmann
berichtet daraufhin der Kindermörder
habe beim Fernsehen folgendes zu ihm
gesagt
tja bei Adelina bin ich noch mal schwach
geworden ne wenn das stimmt was es tut
mir leid dass ich so formulieren muss
aber was für ein zynisches Schwein
dieser Kerl also wenn es stimmt aber
genau das lässt sich nicht überprüfen
die Kripo nimmt den Hinweis ernst und
holt Mark Hoffmann aus der JVA Oldenburg
ab die Ermittler fahren mit ihm ins
pastorenwäldchen wo Adelina gefunden
wurde sie konfrontieren ihn mit einer
lebensgroßen Puppe die sie dort abgelegt
haben aber Mark Hoffmann zeigt keinerlei
Reaktion geschweige denn dass er etwas
gesteht übrigens in der Haft soll er
auch noch mit anderen Morden geprallt
haben die ließen sich aber leider nicht
überprüfen am 20 Jahrestag von adelinas
Tod im Jahr 2021 gab es noch mal viele
Berichte in den Medien aber keine neue
Spur
Polizeisprecherin Franka hettke sagte
damals gegenüber Radio Bremen
ungelöste Altfälle wie der von Adelina
werden wiederkehrend von der Polizei
Bremen und der Staatsanwaltschaft Bremen
dahingehend einer Betrachtung unterzogen
ob es neue Sach- oder Personen Hinweise
gibt die zur Aufklärung des Falls führen
könnten dies passiert alle zwei bis vier
Jahre
weißt du Mirko wir haben ja eingangs
schon über den Begriff Cold Case an sich
gesprochen und jetzt nach diesem Fall
fällt mir noch was auf wir haben ja
immer wieder so ungelöste Fälle hier bei
Tatort Deutschland allerdings ja und wir
hoffen ja auch immer ein bisschen dass
so eine Berichterstattung im Podcast
vielleicht noch mal Hinweise bringt
darauf wollte ich hinaus wenn jemand
einfach spurlos verschwindet dann kann
er ja theoretisch freiwillig
verschwunden sein aber bei cold cases wo
ein Mord nicht aufgeklärt wird da hat
jemand fast so etwas wie das perfekte
Verbrechen begangen das macht ein wütend
das so etwas trotz all der modernen
Polizeiarbeit noch geht also das jemand
mordet und damit einfach davon kommt ja
und deshalb hier noch mal ausdrücklich
unsere bitte wer Hinweise im Mordfall
Adelina hat kann sich an das BKA wenden
das Online-Formular dazu findet ihr in
den Show Notes jeder kleine Hinweis auch
wenn ihr denkt dass er noch so unwichtig
ist aber denkt nicht fünf oder sechs mal
drüber nach sondern wendet euch lieber
an die Polizei und wer weiß vielleicht
kann der Mörder von Adelina noch
gefunden werden diesen Fall haben wir
aufgeschrieben mit Hilfe von Artikeln
der Sendung Butten und binnen von Radio
Bremen mit Berichten aus Bild und Bild
am Sonntag sowie einer Zusammenfassung
von T-Online Redaktion und Skript Stefan
Netzeband Schnitt Antonia Heyer
Postproduktion durch die weight watch
Studios München ich bin Mirko Kasimir
und ich freue mich wenn ihr beim
nächsten Mal auch wieder dabei seid das
hoffe ich auch macht's gut eure Toni und
euer Mirko